how did i learn to meditate  the beatles taught me i mean not  literally  what they did is they went to india and  they came back and they told everybody  about transcendental meditation and i  thought well okay that sounds cool i'll  try it and so i went to um a place a  little town house where they uh taught  meditation i brought my flowers i paid  my fee and so on and i learned then  transcendental meditation and you know  thank god for it because it has had  probably more of an impact than anything  on my life because it has given me an  equanimity a clarity and a calmness to  be able to approach all the things that  we need to approach that i need to  approach and the capacity to learn and  all that and it also gave me a  creativity because it brings you into  your subconscious mind where creativity  fly flows from and so that's how i came  about it and that's why i recommend it